it was just a few
just two weeks before he passed i'm so
scared that i'm gonna
pull up his text and then accidentally
delete it one day like it scares me so
much
because i don't ever want to lose this
candace cameron beret tears up sharing
her last text messages from bob saget
during an interview with today's hoda
copy the actress reveals she had a small
spat with the late comedian we were
gonna have dinner
and we got into a little tiff
and his flight was delayed we ended up
not having dinner
but
in in bob fashion
the next day he wrote me
like what would be
pages long
of a text
he was apologizing saying he was cranky
and he was just so he was just so sorry
thankfully candace says they resolved it
quickly and bob's final message well it
was full of love he said at the end
i love you more for the trouble you're
giving me if that's even possible
and i wrote
back i love you i could never be mad at
you
roll my eyes at you yes but never mad
when you care about somebody
especially now i'm finding you got to
let them know candace who played bob's
on-screen daughter dj on full house also
touches on a side of the comedian fans
rarely saw he was so emotionally
available
all the time and he was really the first
person
in my life as a man that i saw
um
cry and and have those emotions right at
the forefront
of his conversations if you were hurting
he would hurt with you you would see the
tears well up in his eyes but ultimately
the mother of three says she's still
having difficulty processing everything
i can't believe he's gone forever i just
can't i my my brain has not
comprehended that yet
you know i think for for even tv viewers
again you might think like oh
he he played your dad on tv but bob was
so much more than that
you're the best oh i am
bob's death has had an impact on the
entire full house cast including john
stamos since the stand-up comic died on
january 9th john has been paying tribute
to his late pal sharing fond memories
like this
[Music]
but he's keeping the humor alive posting
this cute video of his son billy
this is funny
the grandfathered star explains in the
caption billy was never interested in
full house and i was perfectly fine with
that bob died now he's obsessed i blame
bob the last four years we started to
become
close the last four years of the eight
year run of the first one and then since
then
we literally
are brothers
the cast of the 90s sitcom came together
for bob's private memorial last month
john and candace went so did jody
sweeten mary kate and ashley olsen
laurie lachlan and dave coulier
made you a ham sandwich dave dave here's
my sweet friend dave dave plays joey on
the show pretty much eats all the time
most of the cast including bob reunited
for the revival series fuller house in
2016. when the show came to an end in
2020 all bob could feel was gratitude
you know it's it's emotional yeah and we
love each other and we've been friends
all these years
and we've been there for each other and
people have heard all this ad nauseam
but it's
it's honestly true i mean it's a it's an
extended family
[Music]
you